hey there I'm Kris Pilon on the set of  the new Armani code commercial there's a  reason why ladies love mr. pine and he  does get the girl in his new Armani ad  but who knew he was so sensitive world  of modelling fascinates me to no end and  is not for me because often times people  are just looking about how fat or skinny  or I just couldn't deal with it I don't  have thick enough skin quite honest  Chris shows off is a row excited along  with Casey Affleck in their new movie  with the finest hours opening today it's  the true tale of a daring sea rescue and  it was not an easy shoot there was a  gentleman in text with a fire hose  pointed at us at all times in between  them during takes who seemed to get a  lot of sadistic gratification out of  making the actors miserable but if  you're looking for something a little  different also in theaters today 50  shades of black and one blue Panda 3